a police report we now have shed some  new light on the destructive series of  events yesterday in Henderson it all  happened right around noon right here  near Paradise Hills and College Drive  Henderson Police now say 19-year-old  Mark ellsworth's mother called 9-1-1  yesterday she said her son was having a  mental breakdown he allegedly threatened  to burn the family home down when police  arrived the fire was already underway  officers say Ellsworth walked out and  pointed a gun at them police responded  by firing by firing three shots no one  was injured and Ellsworth was taken into  custody he's due in court tomorrow